that's my van no I'm less lift here it's  good okay  I'll catch you in Chicago we met with  people in big cities like Chicago  including flavors.you leader there to  learn about how they think about work  you'd really span the spectrum from  small all the way to large you know  China is much more than the Beijing  Olympics much more than cheap exports  much more than all the competitiveness  that you hear in the news the access  that Stanford gets you is unbelievable  and you see that firsthand on a GST tax  will spring air plug and play can be an  incubator the Fonz's innovation hub crit  co delivery hero which is like a door -  of in europe we went to rocket internet  a GSE is an adventure it's also packed  but it's a chance to go outside the  bubble it's a bonding experience it's a  lot of fun it's educational it's a  touching time with your classmates it's  transformational  [Music]